محمد انتهى الاقتحام الاسرائيلي الى في
مخيم جنين منذ نحو الدقائق معدوده الفريق
متوجه الى هناك انا مازلت متواجد هنا في
مدينه رام الله وفقي وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه فان هذا الهجوم الاسرائيلي على
المخيم اصفر عن سقوط سته فلسطينيين وعدد
ايضا كبير من الجرحى من بين هؤلاء
الفلسطينيين عبد الفتاح خروشه الذي تتهمه
القوات الاسرائيليه بتنفيذ عمليه حواره
قبل نحو تسعه ايام والتي اسفرت عن مقتل
مستوطنين اثنين عبد الفتاح خروشه عمره 49
عاما من سكان مخيم عسكر في مدينه نابلس
وكان معتقلا في السجون الاسرائيليه لمده
ثمانيه سنوات وافرج عنه فقط قبل اسبوعين
عبد الفتاح وايضا عدد من المقاتلين كانوا
يتواجدون في المنطقه الشرقيه في مخيم جنين
عندما داهمت قوه اسرائيليه خاصه الساعه
الرابعه عصرا بتوقيت فلسطين المنزل الذي
كان يت فيه اطلقوا على هذا المنزل نحو
تسعه صواريخ
واعلن بعدها الجيش الاسرائيلي عن قتل
هؤلاء الشبان بينهم عبد الفتاح داخل
المخيم ايضا خلال هذه العمليه كان هناك
محاوله لمقاتلين لعشرات المقاتلين من
المخيم لفك الحصار عن هذا البيت ما ادى
لاشتباكات عنيفه سواء في مخيم جنين او في
مدينه جنين اوقات هذا العدد من الضحايا
ايضا شاركت في هذا في هذا الهجوم على نحو
اللافت الطائره اسرائيليه مروحيه من نوع
اباتشي واطلقت بلالين حراريه في سماء
المخيم اضافه الى الطائرات المسيره التي
كانت تجوب سماء المخيم حاليا القوات
الاسرائيليه انسحبت من المخيم وتجري عمليه
تشييع
جثامين الضحايا الذين يعني بعضهم تم
انتشاله اشلاء من بين انقاذ المنزل الذي
دمر بالصواريخ الاسرائيليه وهذا الاقتراح
ياتي في اطار محاولات للتهدئه في المنطقه
خاصه في ظفار الغربيه هل هناك تخوف
فلسطيني من استمرار تلك الاقتحامات
هذا ما ذكره بيان للرئاسه الفلسطينيه صدر
قبل قليل وايضا من منظمه التحرير قالوا ان
اسرائيل تشن حربا مفتوحه على الفلسطينيين
وانها لم تلتزم لا بتفاهمات قمه العقبه
ولا باي وسطات سواء وسطات عربيه او وسطات
امريكيه وان هذا الهجوم الدموي الكبير على
مدينه جنين والذي ياتي بعد في اعقاب هجوم
مماثل كان على مدينه نابلس وايضا على
مدينه جنين في بدايه هذا العام هذه
الهجمات والاقتحامات في منتصف النهار على
المدن الفلسطينيه من شانها ان تنسف اي
محاولات للتهدئه وتعيد يعني الجميع الى
المربع الاول وايضا من شانها ان تجلب
عمليات ردود فعل فلسطينيه وبالتالي
الاستمرار اراقه الدماء واستمرار عجله
العنف وتطالب سواء الراعي الامريكي
لتفاهمات العقبه وايضا المجتمع الدولي
لضروره التدخل لكبح جماح هذه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه التي تقول عنها
السلطه الفلسطينيه انها يعني تشن حربا لها
ولا فيها على الفلسطينيين منذ ان اتت الى
سده الحكم عبد الحفيظ جوان شكرا جزيلا لك